Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Before we begin with the questions,
inshallah
I have a question
for everyone here.
Let's see who amongst us knows the
answer to this question for the benefit
of all the rest of us.
There's a narration in
where the companions
narrated to us the way that the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam would make
he
would make salah outside of the masjid.
Actually he'd make salah outside of the
city limits.
He sai wasam along with all the other
companions from Medina.
Everyone
would go to the outskirts of Medina
out to the desert where it was flat.
There's nothing there.
And he would make there most of us, many
of us know this already.
The question that I have is a detail
that the companions mentioned
that is a little bit curious. They
mentioned that when he would go
that when he would go,
he would have one of his companions,
whether it's Bil or whether it's Ib
Masoud or whoever, any one of his
servants or companions,
he would have them carry with them
something that is called a anaz.
[Silence]
in the Arabic language is a lance.
What were you going to say?
[Arabic recitation]
What is
is still alive. One of my first mash,
he'd always say,
and then the person would be like,
very good. But you're wrong.
It's a It's a lance,
right? Huh?
So, it's a lance. It's a spear, but
it's shorter, right? Spears are very
long. This is a lance. It's a very short
lance that usually would be used with a
shield. So, they'd take that with them
out into the desert for something. He'd
use it. What were they using that for?
Why would he have them take this? And
why is this detail important that the
companions felt they needed to tell us
about it? Any
takers?
What What would you imagine
a spear needs to be for? Huh?
Protection.
It is for a type of protection, but not
the kind of protection we're thinking
[Arabic recitation]
He would use it as a sutra.
A sutra in the Arabic language is a
covering. That's what it literally
translates to, a covering. Because the
desert is flat and because they'd go to
a flat area, he would take this spear,
this land, and it would be stuck in the
ground for him to pray towards so that
it's not open in front of him. It would
be stuck in the ground ahead of him and
he would pray towards it. Right
now
he mentioned our brother mentioned an
addition there a hashia which is so that
people wouldn't move in front of him or
walk in front of him. Everybody's behind
him. Who's going to be walking around in
the desert in front of him? Nobody. He's
the imam in the front. He's got this
lance right in front of him. He prays
towards it and makes a salah towards it.
This is called a sutra.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam said in
Muslim about this.
He saidnone of you is to pray
except
to a sutra in front of him.
Meaning anytime you pray, you have to
pray towards a
a covering or a shield, which is
exactly what it means and translates to
a sutra.
And what this means is that anytime a
person goes to pray, he's commanding the
companions, you never pray with it just
open in front of you.
Even if you're out in the desert all by
yourself,
you always pray towards a sutra. The
exact wording of the hadith, none of you
is to pray except to a sutra in front of
him. Now, a sutra could be anything.
Obviously, he took the lance because it
could be stuck in the ground. It would
remain erect on its own. But it could be
anything. A wall, a pillar.
If he found himself traveling, he would
use his camel and pray towards it and
the the saddle that's on the camel and
sometimes they would st the companions
would stack up stones in front of them
and pray towards those. Sometimes even
Iban Abbass if he was in the masid and
couldn't find an adequate sutra he would
pray towards the back of the person that
is in front of him. They would always
pray towards a sutra.
Why would they pray towards a sutra? The
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
tells us because a shan
passes in front of a person during his
prayer
and
depletes the reward of a person's prayer
even if they're praying alone.
This is something unseen, something we
can't we can't see.
And so we're commanded to pray towards a
sutra. And the sutra is also very
important in a public area so that
people know that you're praying and that
you set up a parameter for yourself to
where someone would not pass between you
and your sutra. The prophet sallall.aii
wasallam
would pray and keep the distance between
himself and his sutra as three cubits.
What are three cubits?
In the Arabic language is from the elbow
to the tip of the middle finger. This is
called a dra. Right now notice that the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam's cubit is
going to be longer than mine and yours
because they were much bigger in their
bodies back then. But as our bodies got
smaller and our cubits got shorter,
the same distance is to be kept with our
cubits from ourselves and our sutra. So
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
commanded that if a person is in the
masid in the wild by himself at home
wherever a person is alone in company
and especially if a person is leading
salah as an imam they always pray
towards a sutra. Often times we see a
person will come into the masid, stand
at the very back of the masid with the
whole masid in front of them and start
praying. And then you watch, you observe
this and you see people are kind of
confused. How close is too close for me
to pass in front of them? Right? So
sometimes people will see someone
praying all the way in the back. They'll
walk. They're trying to cross over this
way. They'll walk all the way like
there's a fence there to behind them and
come all the way back in the front. This
is unnecessary. The prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam sutra is three cubits
ahead of him. Meaning that when he would
make sujud, there was about a foot as
described in Bkari between his head and
the wall or the sutra that he would be
making salah in front of. And so
what is the maximum
distance
or the minimum distance that a person
can cross in front of another person
making salah? Because we all know it's
haram to walk across someone making
salah. Correct. The question is how far
ahead?
Anybody know?
Very good.
The place where their head would be in
sujud.
The four mib
mention at most three cubits
which is a little bit past where your
head would be in sujud mjut.
This is the maximum distance that is
reserved for a person when they are
praying. If a person walks across beyond
that distance in front of a person,
they're not walking in front in front of
the person's prayer. What is walking in
front of a person is between them and
their place of sujud as the scholars
and jurists mention
anything beyond that it's not walking in
front of them. So for instance here in
our masjid we have these lines. When a
person makes sjud they have this line in
front of them.
If a person were to cross in front of
another person beyond this line that
distance is sufficient.
Beyond that they don't have to
they don't have to avoid walking in
front of a person because walking in
front of a person praying is only
considered walking across a person's
prayer when it is between them and their
place of sujud. So having said that
inshallah I know that last week I had
mentioned that we would start directly
with the questions but sometimes I feel
a cold start with questions. the
juices aren't really flowing yet and so
people don't really have any questions.
There's kind of an icebreaker inshallah.
So we'll start with the questions now.
just pertaining to what you just said
about sutra does this apply in Caba and
Medina Madina.
[Arabic recitation]
is does this issue of having a sutra
apply in Mecca and Medina?
The majority of the scholars who who
view this rule as being applicable and a
person is to adhere by this rule of not
crossing in front of a person in Salah.
Most of them mention that this is
specific for Mecca, not for Medina.
Right? Mecca because of the way that the
prayer is set up around the cabba.
Everywhere around that cabba is the
direction of salah. Whereas in Medina,
it's all one direction. Everybody is
facing. So there's less of a need to
have to cross in front of someone in
order to get out. But in Mecca, it it's
almost anywhere you go, you're
passing in front of someone. And so the
correct opinion is that a person is to
avoid
crossing in front of another person
praying anywhere they are whether Mecca
or elsewhere. However,
if it is necessary to do so then it is
permissible in Mecca and possibly in
Medina in the opinion of some scholars
when it is needed when it is necessary.
Now, it doesn't mean that a person
should just be strolling around you
know, walking in front of everybody as
they're praying, even if they're at the
Cabba. The reason that the scholars view
Mecca and some mention Medina as
exempted from this ruling is not
necessarily because of the place, but
because of the sheer amount of people
and the sheer amount of influx of people
that will make it almost impossible for
a person to move or leave or come in or
enter adequately without having to
cross in front of someone. So in the
situation where a person is in Mecca in
Medina, some scholars mention
anywhere where it is excessively
overpacked
and and and it's not possible to move
around then it becomes an issue of
necessity and it becomes permissible.
But a person should always be conscious
of this and not you know make a habit
of crossing in front of somebody praying
even if they're at the Caba or Mecca.
Very good question. But another part
of the question is should a person still
use a sutra if they're praying in Mecca?
And the answer is yes. All of the
scholars view that as being preferred
if a person is able to do so. Right? The
issue that the scholars exempted was
walking in front of someone who's
praying, not necessarily you taking a
sutra. But it's permissible and and the
prayer is valid if a person doesn't have
a sutra albeit their reward is is can be
grossly depleted.
now
okay over here we got two we got over
[Arabic recitation]
these etiquette of the salah?
Okay. So this is another very good
question. As soon as they are able to
understand the teaching,
right? Whether they be 3 years old or
four years old, as soon as they're able
to understand the difference between
this is right and this is wrong, this is
my right hand and this is my left hand.
this is appropriate and this is
inappropriate. At that moment, we begin
teaching these etiquets, right?
Sometimes people fail to do that
because they say, "Well, you know, it's
just a kid." No, kids, kids need to
learn these things as soon as they're
able in order to start to see the world
around them as structured in the way
that Allah has commanded, rather as
being something that they turn on and
off a switch depending on where
they are. So as soon as an a child
reaches the age of te
means the age of discrepancy where
they're able to discriminate between
right and wrong and good and bad and
then they should be taught this right
and at the age of seven when they begin
to pray when they are commanded to pray
now now they are to be held accountable
for breaking these rules.
But sometimes it's a a very young
child a toddler that has no idea
what they're being, you know, shued away
for or even an animal. So in Sah Muslim,
the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam was praying and he was leading
the companions in salah and suddenly a
sheep came running across and was going
to cross in front of him right they were
in the masjid a person may say what's a
sheep doing in the masjid the masjid
didn't have doors okay it was just open
it was open air place and it didn't even
have a ceiling only the front had some
kind of tent over it and So, , sheep
would come in and dogs and and and foxes
would come in and snakes would get in
and so forth. And so, a sheep wandered
into the masjid one day. And while he
was in prayer, he saw the sheep coming
to cross in front of him. The companion
said that he walked forward in prayer
until his stomach was against the wall
of the masid and the sheep walked behind
him and then he backed back up and took
his former position in salah. So even an
animal a person is not to allow anything
to cross in front of him while he is in
salah. And this might mean that a
person has small children. They're still
not old enough to understand that when
I'm praying, don't come in front of me.
Maybe you need to have a a room with a
with a door that when you pray, you go
in there to pray, right? Until the
children are old enough to understand
not to cross in front of mom and dad
when they're in salah. Now,
I think brother Well here had a
question. Yes.
[Arabic recitation]
It's kind of a follow-up question
or maybe just two follow-up question.
One for today and the one two weeks ago.
I didn't have chance to follow up but
for tonight you you mentioned that sutra
[Arabic recitation]
a hadith ofas
that talks about the the sin of that
where he mentioned you'll be either
going back 40 and some people said is 40
40 days 40 years.
[Arabic recitation]
that? So that's just a follow up on
that. So this is the the narration
you're referring to is the narration of
in which he told his companions his
students
said
[Silence]
he for
so the narration that you're referring
to is is the narration of
and in this narration he said that I
heard the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam say if the person cry crossing
in front of another insah only knew the
kind of punishment for doing so that
awaits him. He would stand there for 40.
Meaning he would rather stand there and
wait for him to finish his prayer. Even
if that were to stand there for 40 and
then he stopped. So his student said 40
what? 40 years. He said, "I refuse to
say anything." They said, "40 months."
He said, "I refuse." What this means is
that Abu Huray was uncertain of that
last part of the narration. Was it
years? Was it months? Was it weeks? He
couldn't remember. So, he didn't want to
say anything that the prophet didn't
say. Sallallam.
So, he said 40. Many of the scholars if
not most of the the scholars that
explain the this hadith
they mentioned that the correct opinion
is that it is 40 years right meaning
a for 40 years of they would rather
stand for 40 years there than cross and
interrupt a slave and his master in
prayer if they only knew
what repercussions awaited them for
doing so in the hereafter. So it's a
very stern warning against taking
another person's salah for granted.
never walk in front of a person praying
and that's not just in prayer but from
this narration we understand any
disruption of prayer. any disruption of
prayer, loud voices, loud sounds,
doing things that will interrupt
anyone's prayer.
You never want to impede a man or woman
trying to earn Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala's favor and someone who is
engaged with Allah in that very sacred
exchange that is
[Arabic recitation]
ago I just don't want to stop but when
you mentioned that parents have to be
fair with their kids.
[Arabic recitation]
to give the other one.
time did not permit. So what if for
instance you set up certain things
because you wanted to reward the kids
based on you say okay if you guys do
your chores you will get this and get
that. What if one of them gets it the
other one doesn't and then you end up
rewarding one? Is that considered that
you're not fair or you're not supposed
to even do that?
[Arabic recitation]
considered fair. Why? because both of
them had a fair opportunity,
right? So, I have two kids. I say,
"Guys, you got to clean the dishes, take
out the trash, blah blah blah, and
whoever does that gets $5, right? One of
them did that and the other didn't. I
gave one and not the other." Why? Not
because I'm giving them a gift. Because
the narration is speaking about giving a
gift, right? If you give a gift to one
of your children, you have to give the
rest of them. However, this is not a
gift. This is something that they earn.
You gave them both the opportunity
equally. One of them capitalized on it,
the other did not. There's nothing wrong
with this at all. And this is one of the
ways that even the companions
would raise their children and and
commend their children for for doing
good deeds and and reprimand them for
not doing right. Reward is not just
punishment. Reward is also a part of the
equation in raising children. Now
[Arabic recitation]
that brother over there had a question.
So what are the requirements for the
sutra? Can it be a static object like
the wall or do you have to physically
place it? And if you do physically place
it, are there height requirements? Are
there any width requirements? Anything
that? Very good. So, I I'll mention
something to you as an anecdote and
maybe someone here could relate,
but
my mother,
she used to say all the time, tell me a
little, a little knowledge is dangerous.
Meaning when you don't have the full
story,
it can be very dangerous to implement
half of a teaching. So when I was a kid,
they would teach us the our elders in
and you know fall when I was growing up,
they would teach us that your sutra when
you put something in front of you as a
sutra, it has to be something that can
draw blood.
Something that can draw blood. What does
that mean? Someone somewhere,
Allah knows who, probably picked up a
book and saw that it was a spear and
made this deduction somehow and it
started to be as almost a wives tail
that your sutra has to be able to draw
blood. So he they would tell us you can
use a a nail, you can use a thumbtack,
you can use a sewing needle, you know,
anything that draws blood.
This is not at all correct or
relevant. rather the sutra has no
width requirement and it has no depth
requirement. The only requirement that
the sutra has that the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam mentioned is a
height requirement. And the height is
he said
that the sutra should be relative in
height to the end of a camel's
saddle.
Now I'll explain what that means. So the
saddle of a camel is very different than
a horse. But to make a long story short,
when people would sit on their camel,
they had a stick,
, kind of board, better to say, a
board that would come out at the back of
the saddle and it would stand up like
this and you could lean your back up
against it while you were riding, kind
of a, you know, a back rest
while you were riding. This is called
and Iben Mandur and others of the
scholars mention that
is about a cubit and a fourth. So it's
about a cubit and a little bit that is
the height the average height of
so when the prophet sallallah.aihi
alaihi wasallam told the companions it
should be at least the height of the
back rest of a camel saddle. It is
roughly a cubit and a little bit or a
cubit. Even if it's less than a cubit, a
little bit less. So we could say a cubit
is roughly 18 in let's say right? It
would be if it were 16 or 15 in or if it
were 22 in that's not a problem right
it's an approximation
the minimum height requirement is all
that is necessary the next thing is that
the sutra should be from the ground up
meaning that if it hangs or is above the
ground then it would not count. So for
instance, let's say there were curtains
hanging and they are that long but they
are not touching the ground. This would
not be a sutra. Or let's say for
instance I have a table
and I pray towards the center not
towards the legs of the table. This
would not be a sutra. A sutra has to
start from the ground or touch the
ground and go up. These are the two
requirements that the Islamic jurists
mention with regards to the
parameters of what a sutra is and what
kind of sutra is considered valid. Very
good question.
I think we could probably take maybe one
or two more questions real quick. You
got one here and you got one over there.
Go ahead over there and then come back
here. And this guy's double dipping. You
know, double dipping is is bad manners
in America, right? Okay. Go ahead.
Asalam alalaykum.
[Arabic recitation]
where you can't be certain about the
direction of the
[Arabic recitation]
direction this direction but you tried
your best to to pray to the direction
of the
[Arabic recitation]
a whole day you discovered that actually
it was not accurate. It was a little bit
the other direction. So what should
you do about your salah? Should you make
up for the ones or what exactly happens
here? Okay. So
this exact thing happened to the
companions
while they were traveling with the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam. So
the caravan it was a cloudy night and
they had lost their bearings and they
couldn't see the stars. So they were not
certain which direction the pibla was
and so some companions prayed in one
direction others prayed in another
direction they weren't praying together
okay but they were each you know each
person is in his tent or whatever in his
area and he's think I my best judgment
is the is this way so the companions
actually made lines in the sand or in
the dirt so that the next morning when
the sun rose they'd be able to determine
who had actually made salah in the
correct direction
and obviously they were opposing
directions so some of them were wrong
and only one of them was right. However,
none of them was commanded by the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam to
remake his salah and none of them remade
their salah because they asked and he
did not instruct them to redo their
salah. Why? Because
that is the overarching
principle upon which all commands of
Allah are built and that is no soul
shall be burdened beyond its ability.
You are commanded to make salah towards
the you are commanded to make and try to
use your best judgment and every tool at
your disposal to make sure that your
salah is in the correct direction. If
you use everything you can and you do
your best to make salah in that correct
direction and then later find out that
it was in the wrong direction, your
prayer is valid and you do not have to
make up your salah. Second of all, there
is a part that you didn't ask about
but perhaps would be beneficial and that
is how accurate
is making salah towards the that is
necessary. What kind of accuracy is
necessary? I mean do I have to use a
laser compass? Do I have to use
satellite GPS coordination? , do I
have to use ballistic charts to make
sure that my salah is exactly exactly
towards the center of the the Kaa? The
answer is no. The answer is no. And that
is the opinion of the three other than
the and that is that
explain the verse in.
So he said the verse states to face
towards the approximate direction of the
kappa. What is approximate?
The scholars of Phil have said that it
is 35°.
35 degrees is an approximation of the
general direction of the right.
so excuse me 35 45° so a
fourth. So 45
degrees is the direction is actually to
my right or to my left.
If the is anywhere within this 30 to 35°
okay some mention a little more it has
to be at least that then the salah is
correct. Most most massaged
are built slightly off especially the
older massagid in many countries most
countries as a matter of fact you
would be hardressed to find a masid that
is pointing precisely towards the cabba
right and even in North America this was
a thing you know in the 80s and 90s
most people were facing towards which
direction
southeast right and then later you know
it became s northeast and so on and so
forth many massaged many were made
towards that direction if a person is
facing
south east or northeast you've got
this kind of thing going on as long as
you do not have your face completely
away from the thel the salah is correct
And so 30 35° off this is acceptable
as an approximation of the direction of
the I can't remember a single major
masid that I was a part of that I served
in in which eventually someone will come
to me as the imam and bring me a bunch
of paperwork and a bunch of essays
talking about the masid is actually 3°
off of the Kaa and so what do you want
me to do? You want me to tear the masid
down and rebuild it? What what is your
solution here? And they want to make a
big fitna about it and a big issue and
we got to put lines and instead of
facing this way, we need to change three
degrees and have all the lines f this is
insanity, right? It's not a ballistic
missile. It's not a tra it's not a
projectile that is going to make it
over. We don't have to you know worry
about gravity and the coralis effect and
so forth in our salah. It is an
approximation. In the time of the
companions
the prophet sallall.aii Wasallam said
and Muslim he said if the if the
south is to your left and the north is
to your right then pray. That is for
them when they were where
when they moved to Medina they would
make their salah towards the towards the
west. When they later changed and
started to make their salah towards the
east, which is towards Mecca, they north
would be on your left. The south would
be to your right. And you would make
salah. We all know that Mecca is
slightly south
east. It's not exactly east, but that's
how he taught the companions to pray.
That's where
got this.
If our salah had to be precisely to the
then we would not be able to make our
rose any wider than the ka is correct
because if we made our rose or in the
masid wider than the ka somebody
invariably is going to be praying off
of the ka but none of the fukah have
come to this conclusion. So a slight
deviation from the exact direction of
the Cabba is acceptable. It's not only
acceptable but it is expected. Now
we'll have one last very quick is it a
quick question or we got to keep it till
next week.
[Arabic recitation]
Let's go.
minutes over here.
[Arabic recitation]
I heard something a little bit
concerning and it came to mind
because we're on the topic of salah and
the parenting came up. I heard that
someone taught their kid that
if they miss the salah then the rest of
their prayers are invalid. So I want to
you know clear that up. No, there's no
narration that is authentic that
articulates that one prayer
one prayer's invalidity or one prayer's
mi one prayer missed has any effect
on another prayer and a narration of
this meaning that whoever misses fudar
then the rest of their prayers are
invalid is not a narration It's not only
I wouldn't even say it's not an
authentic narration. It's not even a
narration
and it's a it would could never be a
narration because that doesn't fit the
pattern of the way that the laws of the
Quran and Sunnah are set up.
Furthermore, these kinds of mis
quotings and kinds of fables and stuff,
they are tools in the hands of a shanim
to destroy the Muslims
will and to break down our our
march to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
comes and he says remember whoever
misses fud the rest of their prayer
isn't valid. Now we got a guy say,
"Well, what's the point of praying? It's
not going to be valid anyways. I'll
start again tomorrow." This is more
dangerous than poison. It's more
dangerous upon the Muslims than alcohol
and gambling. It's more dangerous than a
loaded gun. These kinds of
misconceptions and misquotations of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
Thank you very much for bringing that
up.
[Arabic recitation]
Well, you know, the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said the question that
our brother Abu Gazi is Abui mentioned
is that what what is the reaction or
what is the course of action for a
person who has someone attempt to pass
in front of them? The pro right? So the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
meaning stop him if he tries to cross
path and he said
he said and if the person insists to
cross in front of you after alerting
them that you're praying and not to
cross in front of them then fight them
off because with them is a shan
some of the fukah have even mentioned
you know very interesting things
regarding this issue but the meaning of
the narration is that you are not to
allow anyone to pass in front of you and
if they insist on crossing you are to
insist on stopping them from crossing.
However,
what about if it's someone that
sheep that tried to cross in front of
him? If he was unable to walk and make
the sheep cross behind him and that
sheep insisted on crossing in front of
him, would he have fought with the
sheep? The answer is no, right? Because
it's unable to understand. It doesn't
know what's going on. A small child,
same thing. A non-Muslim
at at work is the same thing because
they have no idea what you're doing.
Right? So in that kind of situation, you
would not hit someone or fight with them
or anything that. The point of the
narration is to alert the person that
you're praying and how far in front of
you just the place of sujud right here.
And most people feel too uncomfortable
to come that close to another person
anyways. It's unnatural to be that close
walking by a stranger. Most of us don't
do this, right? And so that is the
meaning of the narration. Now some
people they take it too far. for
instance as soon as someone tries to
walk in front of them they'll hit them
or they'll push them violently. This is
not permissible obviously. And
another thing is
you know I'll mention this very quickly.
Often times people misunderstand this as
being for anyone who is in salah.
And that's not correct. So if you are
praying in Jama and you have an im that
only applies to the im.
It doesn't apply to anybody else in the
in the in the salah.
When you are in salah, your im is your
or as the the say
that the imutra is the sutra of the
people behind him. So if people walk
between the rows or it will not
invalidate or affect a person's prayer
at all. And maybe most of us even
have been in the situation where maybe
you remember that you don't have wudoo
or you need to leave the masid. You're
in salah and the rows are all set up.
You try to come out of the prayer and
you get an arm on this side. Then you
turn around to go out the other way. You
get another arm and you're stuck there
standing waiting for people to finish
prayer. This is ignorance. If a person
has to leave the prayer, they leave and
walk out between the rows. No problem at
all. The next person steps forward and
they fill in those gaps. If a person
were to come in and observe the front
row is not full, for instance, and
there's other rows, they can come in in
front of the rose rock between them and
fill in those gaps. Actually, that would
be obligatory is to fill in the front
rows before the rear ones.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Seven. Love.